- [Instructor] So this
diagram right over here
describes a food web.
And a food web models
how energy and matter
moves in an ecosystem.
And we're going to use this food web
to answer some questions,
to make sure we understand food webs.
So the first thing I'm
going to ask you is,
what are the producers in this food web.
Pause this video and see
if you can figure this out.
All right, now let's work
through this together.
The producers are the ones
that can take matter in the
ecosystem, in the environment,
and energy from an outside
source, usually the sun,
in order to construct themselves
and also in order to store that energy.
And when you look at a food web,
producers are going to have
arrows pointed away from them.
So they're getting their energy
and their matter from the environment
and then other people are
going to consume them.
And we're gonna talk about
them in a little bit.
But we can see here that
the kelp is a producer.
This is an aquatic ecosystem
that we're looking at.
But the kelp is a producer.
There's no arrows going into it
so it's using the sun and
elements and atoms and molecules
that it's finding in its
environment in order to grow.
And we can also see that's the
case with the phytoplankton.
It's also able to do
photosynthesis, like the kelp,
and capture that energy from the sun.
Now, the next question I have
is, where are the decomposers?
Pause the video and
try to answer that one.
All right.
Now you might remember decomposers,
you can think about that's where a lot
of the energy and the matter ends up,
to be decomposed and then recycled again
and be reused again by the producers.
And if you're looking at a food web,
these would-be organisms
where all of the arrows point to them,
but you don't have any
arrows coming from them.
And over here, it's
clear that the bacteria,
and there's many different
species of bacteria
or many different types of bacteria,
but the bacteria here are the decomposers.
Next, I am going to ask you
about the primary consumers.
Pause this video and see
if you can identify them.
Well, primary consumers are consumers
that directly eat the producers.
And so let's see, who is eating the kelp?
You have have the sea
urchin eating the kelp.
You have the fish eating the kelp.
Who's eating the phytoplankton?
You have the zooplankton
eating the phytoplankton.
So these are primary consumers.
Next, let's think about
secondary consumers.
Secondary.
These are those that
eat primary consumers.
Pause the video and think about that.
Well, let's think about
who's eating these primary consumers.
You have the otter.
What's interesting is the
fish is a primary consumer
because it consumes kelp,
which is a producer,
but it also can consume
another primary consumer.
So, a fish, or the fish here,
are both primary and secondary consumers.
And then I think we are done.
So you can see the general notions here.
The producers have arrows
going away from them
but no arrows coming into them
because they're getting
their energy from the sun
and they're using the
matter in the ecosystem.
Primary consumers are
eating those producers,
and you can see they have
arrows going into them.
And then they're eaten by other
folks, secondary consumers,
or those that eat the primary consumers.
And then last but not least,
you have the bacteria,
which are decomposers, where
the arrows all point to them
and they continue to use that energy
and then they take those
nutrients, those molecules,
and they put 'em back into the ecosystem
so that it can be recycled again.